the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi today's lecture starts off what
probably is the single most important
topic in the entire course not just
today but in the entire course and it's
a rather sneaky thing in the sense that
it takes a while to grow into it things
have been going so smoothly so far that
perhaps this point there's going to be a
little bit subtle to make and we'll try
to lead into it gradually there were
probably ten different ways to introduce
this topic and whichever one you pick I
think any one of the other nine would
have been better but without any further
ado let me talk about today's lesson in
terms of something called the
directional derivative and indicate in a
manner of speaking that when we deal
with functions of several variables
especially in the case that N equals two
there is a very obvious geometrical
interpretation one that we made some use
of in the previous lecture but which I
hope to make more use of in this
particular lecture let's take a look and
see what the situation is let's suppose
I'm given that w is a function of the
two independent variables x and y and i
have that w is therefore some function
of x and y and i can now talk about the
graph of W which we assume is some
surface okay and I've drawn it in this
particular way I take some point a comma
B in the XY plane on which F is defined
and at that particular point I go to the
corresponding point on the surface which
I call p0 which has coordinates what a B
and C where C is simply F of a comma B
that of course is how you graph a
function of two independent variables
the W coordinate so to speak is simply
the functional value of the x and y
coordinates now what we did last time
was we essentially said look at if we
were to slice this surface by a plane
which was either parallel to the W Y
plane or to the W
explain we get special curves of
intersection and we use this to indicate
the idea of partial derivatives now
without too much imagination I think it
should be very easy for you to visualize
a arbitrary surface over your heads
you're standing at a particular point on
the floor at that point on the floor you
visualize a coordinate axis which we'll
call the x and y axis now obviously you
can move out from the point at which
you're standing along the x axis you can
move out in the direction along the y
axis
you can visualize that how rapidly the
height above your head is changing as
you move out certainly will depend on
whether you're moving along the x axis
or the y axis but the key point at least
a key point from the point of view of
today's lecture is the fact that why
were you restricted to either of these
two directions why couldn't you have
moved in any one of infinitely many
different directions namely from the
point at which you're originating you
can move in any direction at all because
we're assuming at least that the floor
on which you're standing is continuous
its unbroken you can move in these
directions and the idea that you sort of
get can be shown pictorially by saying
look it let's assume that we're at the
point a comma B we have this surface
over I had just as we did before but now
instead of picking a direction either
parallel to the W X plane or to the W Y
plane let's pick some arbitrary
direction s in which to move and now
what I'm saying is if I now take the
plane that passes through this direction
s perpendicular to the XY plane that
plane will also intersect this surface
passing through the point P zero I get a
curve of intersection and I can talk
about the slope of that particular curve
see ultimately this is what we're going
to be talking about now what is the
slope of that particular curve well it's
a derivative it's a derivative of W with
respect to s where all of a sudden with
chosen the s direction over here to be
what we're going to take our derivative
with respect to in other words it seems
to make sense to talk about the
derivative of F in the direction of s
evaluated at the point a comma B in
other words just like we talked about f
sub X of a comma B and F sub y of a
comma B why can't we talk about the
derivative of F evaluated at a comma B
in the direction of s and if we want to
correlate this with the notation in the
text observe that we call that DW d s by
the way notice not the partial of W with
respect to s but the derivative of W
with respect to s remember the partials
were essentially defined in terms of
holding either X or Y constant notice
that in a general directional derivative
idea neither X nor Y is being held
constant notice that x and y are varying
as we move along s notice also by the
way that once x and y are restricted to
move along s they are no longer
independent variables it's a rather
rather interesting point we talk about W
being a function of the two independent
variables x and y but as soon as we pick
that direction s in the xy-plane
x and y have to be very specially
related namely according to the equation
of a straight line that determines s for
that point to beyond the line and that's
why we talk about the WD s W is a
function of a single variable
once you restrict yourself to the
particular direction s at any rate the
question that we want to come to grips
with is how do you find d wdf well here
again is the beauty of our logical
structure by definition this is the same
definition we knew early in part one of
our course the WDS by definition is the
limit as Delta X approaches 0 Delta W
divided by Delta s now the thing is
what's very difficult to compute in real
life is Delta W after all this W
being f of XY F can be a very very
complicated surface and to actually find
the true change in W well heck
we already saw this in part one when we
compared this Delta Y with delta y-tan
to actually find the change in Y was a
much more difficult job than to find the
change in Y to the tangent line what
we're saying here is lookit we already
know how to find the change in W not to
the surface but to the plane which is
tangent to the surface at a point P Sub
Zero in other words we have already
discussed that Delta W 10 is the partial
of effort respect to X evaluated at a
comma B times Delta X plus the partial
of effort respect to Y times a at the
point a comma B times Delta Y and now
what we say is and I've written this to
accentuate it because I have to talk
very strongly about this it's a point
that if I don't make you will most of
you at least will allow me to slip over
this and not even notice that I've
missed something very very crucial but
let me assume that I can approximate
Delta W by Delta W 10 in other words
let's suppose that Delta W is a
reasonable or a Delta W tan is a
reasonable approximation for Delta W you
say well you know what's such a big
assumption about that now I'm going to
save that for the very last part of the
lecture because my belief is that the
subtlety is so great that I would like
to leave that for the very end and go
through as if the subtlety didn't exist
so that you get the computational
feeling as to what's going on here but
here's the interesting point notice that
Delta W is a change in W as you move
from the point a comma B to some other
point in the plane it's a change in
height now obviously that change in W is
going to depend very strongly on what
direction you're moving in on the other
hand how was Delta W tan computed Delta
W tan was computed just by knowing two
special partial derivatives there are
two special directional derivatives
known as the partial derivatives you see
notice that to get Delta W 10
I have made the assumption that all I
have to know is what's happening in the
x-direction and what's happening in the
y-direction everything else being
determined from the function evaluated
at a comma B so this is really a very
strong assumption that Delta W is
determined pretty closely by Delta W 10
and it turns out to be almost
universally true and we're going to save
that part as I say for the end but for
now let's suppose that we are allowed to
replace Delta W by Delta W 10 if we do
that and we go back to our definition
for dw/ds
namely the limit as Delta X approaches
zero Delta W divided by Delta s we now
replace Delta W by Delta W 10 and divide
through by Delta s to find Delta W over
Delta s we have assuming that this is a
legal substitution that Delta W over
Delta s is the partial of F with respect
to X of evaluated a comma B times Delta
X divided by Delta s plus the partial of
F with respect to Y evaluated a comma B
times the partial of x the change in Y
divided by the change in s Delta Y
divided by Delta s now remember in the S
Direction x and y are not independent
variables in fact how are they related
let's isolate our little diagram here so
that we see in what direction we're
moving here we're starting at the point
a comma B and by the way to get the
proper orientation here as I've drawn
the XY plane here imagine the surface
coming out from the blackboard in other
words the height is really being
measured away from the blackboard here
that's where my surface is I move in the
direction of s here is a Delta X here is
a Delta Y s has a constant direction a
constant slope it's a straight line call
the angle that it makes with the
positive x-axis fee notice that no
matter how big Delta X and Delta Y are
they are related by similar triangles to
what the Delta X divided by Delta s
we'll always be cosine V and Delta Y
divided by Delta s will always be sine
fee and therefore if I replace Delta X
divided by Delta s by cosine fee Delta Y
divided by Delta s by sine fee I
obtained that what Delta W divided by
Delta s is equal to the partial of F
with respect to X evaluated at our point
a comma B times the cosine of fee plus
the partial of F with respect to Y
evaluated at a comma B times the sine of
fee where fee is the what the angle that
the direction s makes with the positive
x-axis at any rate notice by the way
that these things are all constants once
S is chosen once the point a comma B is
fixed therefore when I pass to the limit
nothing really changes in other words
this thing that I'm calling the
directional derivative F of F in the
direction of s a value a that a comma B
to exult to be what the partial of F
with respect to X at the point a comma B
times cosine fee plus the partial of F
with respect to Y evaluated a comma B
times the sine of fee and what I'd like
you to notice is that in these two terms
one factor of each term is determined
solely by the point a comma B in other
words notice that these two factors here
are just partial derivatives and have
nothing to do with direction they're
determined solely by the choice of the
function f and the point a comma B on
the other hand notice that these two
factors cosine Phi and sine fee have
nothing to do with F and have to do only
with the direction s itself which again
should make intuitive sense to you that
if you're asking in terms of the surface
being up over your head for a
directional derivative obviously once
the surface is given the directional
derivative should depend on two things
one what point you start at and the
other what direction you move in once
you've started at that particular point
and what direction you move in has
nothing to do with what the surface
looks like over your head
at any rate what we now do is invoke our
dot product notation in other words this
little trick that we talked about when
we learnt dot products this particular
sum can be written very suggestively as
the dot product of two vectors namely I
will write this as what the vector whose
components are F sub X and F sub y
dotted with the vector whose components
are cosine T and sine T because remember
when you dot two vectors in Cartesian
coordinates you multiply them
coefficient by coefficient to make a
long story short the WD s is what it's
this vector F sub whose I component is f
sub X evaluated at a comma B whose J
component is f sub y evaluated at a
comma B I call that vector G of a comma
B I'm going to give that a special name
a little bit later but for now it's very
important to notice that this is not a
number it's an ordered pair of numbers
in other words it's a vector and if you
want to think of this as a vector what
we're saying is what think of the vector
whose I component is the partial of F
with respect to X evaluated at a comma B
whose J component is f sub y evaluated
at a comma B notice that these are
numbers because a and B are fixed
constants here therefore this vector G
of a comma B is a constant vector and
it's in the XY plane it's a two tupple
on the other hand the other vector
cosine Phi sine fee hopefully you
recognize by now is nothing more than
the unit vector in the direction of s
you see this is the unit vector in the
direction of s so if I now a brief you
smile
d wdf evaluated at a comma B in other
words the directional derivative of W in
the direction of s evaluated a comma B
is just my vector G of a comma B dotted
with the unit vector in the direction of
s now observe two things first of all
when you dot this is a constant I can't
change this once a and B are given
this is fixed so all I can vary is you
sub s but you sub s as a unit vector so
the only way I can vary u sub s is to
change its direction notice that for two
vectors of constant magnitude their dot
product is maximum when the two vectors
are parallel in other words this will be
as big as possible when u sub s is
chosen to be in the direction of my
vector G in other words the WDS at a
comma B is maximum in the direction of G
of a comma B that's the first thing to
observe the second thing is is that when
they are parallel the cosine of the
angle between them is 1 so the magnitude
of this vector will just be the product
of these two magnitudes but the
magnitude of U sub s u sub s being a new
vector is 1 therefore the maximum
magnitude not only occurs in the
direction of G but it is also
numerically equal to the magnitude of G
in other words the maximum value of D
WDS evaluated a comma B not only occurs
in the direction of the vector G but
that maximum magnitude is the magnitude
of G evaluated at a comma B for that
reason G of a comma B is given a very
important name and I decided to hold off
on the name until as late as possible so
that the name wouldn't frighten you but
the name is the gradient vector in other
words the vector G of a comma B is
called the gradient of F at a comma B
and it's usually written in this
notation an upside-down Delta it's
called Dell usually with an arrow over
it or in boldface print in a text and
it's written this way and it's red what
the gradient of F evaluated at a comma B
what is the gradient of F evaluated at a
comma B it's the vector which gives you
the hint as to how to compute the
directional derivatives in any direction
that you wish namely in terms of the
gradient vector the directional
derivative of
of F in the direction of s evaluated a
comma B is the gradient of F evaluated
at a comma B dotted with the unit vector
in the direction of s by the way you may
recall that when you dot a vector with a
unit vector you get the projection of
that vector in the direction of the unit
vector in other words the directional
derivative another way of looking at
this physically is nothing more than the
projection of the gradient vector onto
the given direction in which you're
moving and the important point is that
this particular definition does not
depend on our coordinate system what is
interesting is that in Cartesian
coordinates there is a very simple way
of computing the gradient vector namely
the I component of the gradient vector
is just the partial of F with respect to
X and the J component is just the
partial of F with respect to Y but that
was a very special case because you see
I and X happen to have the same
direction as dou Y in J for arbitrary
coordinate systems this need not be true
and I'm going to drill you on that and
the exercises but in others what I'm
saying is remember the gradient vector
in terms of a maximum directional
derivative don't memorize it as a
formula because if you do you're going
to get in trouble for example if I were
to give my surface in polar coordinates
say W is some function of R and theta
then it turns out and there's an
exercise on this and the notes that the
gradient of s is the partial of W with
respect to R times u sub R plus and
here's the big difference 1 over R times
the partial of W with respect to theta
times u sub theta in other words the
gradient vector is not the partial of W
with respect to R times u sub r plus the
partial of W with respect to theta times
u sub theta in others you don't just
mechanically differentiate with respect
to these variables and the key reason
that you can't do this well look at
let's just look at this little diagram
and I think
idea will become very clear remember
that in polar coordinates are as denoted
this way u sub theta is at right angles
to R notice that u sub theta is not in
the direction of theta
notice that the direction of theta is
sort of the tangent to this circle of
radius R at this point if I call this
increment D theta
notice that this arc length is Rd theta
so the vector in the direction of U sub
theta is Rd theta naught D theta I don't
know if you notice that but coming back
up here for a moment notice that this
was okay here because I was in the same
direction as u sub R notice however that
it's ID theta which is in the u sub
theta direction again I leave most of
these details for the notes but I feel
that if I don't say these things to you
it becomes very easy to miss these
points when we talk about them or write
about them that somehow I hope that by
you're hearing me say this you will be
keyed in when you come to these concepts
in the unit that we're studying but I
think the best way to augment what we're
doing is by means of a specific example
let us suppose that we're given the
surface w equals f of X Y where f of X Y
is X to the fifth plus X cubed y plus y
to the fifth and we want to compute the
directional derivative of F at the point
one comma one in the direction let's
call it s sub one where S sub one is the
direction that goes from the point 1
comma 1 to the point 4 comma 5 now what
we're saying is and I guess maybe if we
look at these two diagrams concurrently
what-have-you maybe this will be easier
to see here we are at the point 1 comma
1 we want to see how fast the slope over
I had the the W value is changing in the
direction of s 1 where s 1 is chosen to
be what we were moving from the point 1
comma 1 in the XY plane to the point 4
comma 5 see we're moving in this
direction and we want to see how fast
was changing over our heads which
geometrically means you draw this plane
intersect it with the particular surface
here and this point p0 what we really
want geometrically is what the slope of
the line tangent through this curve in
the WS one playing tangent to this curve
at the point p0 and my claim is is that
this can be done very very easy from a
mechanical point of view now that we
have our gradient vector behind this
namely what we do is given what W looks
like as a function of x and y we take
the partial of W with respect to both X
and Y which hopefully you can all do
quite mechanically now based on our last
units work we differentiate first
holding Y constant then holding X
constant at any rate we obtain what that
the partial of W with respect to X is 5x
to the fourth plus 3x squared Y and so
if we compute that at the point 1 comma
1 when x and y are both 1 this simply
turns out to be a in a similar way the
partial of W with respect to Y is X
cubed plus 6 Y to the fifth so if we
compute that at the point 1 comma 1 that
turns out to be 7 in other words then by
definition of our gradient which is the
partial of F with respect to X evaluated
at 1 comma 1 times I plus the partial of
F with respect to Y evaluated at 1 comma
Y times J the gradient of F at 1 comma 1
is just 8i plus 7j very easy to write
down mechanically when you're using
Cartesian coordinates now let me make a
brief aside an interruption here the
idea is to emphasize what the gradient
vector means what this tells me is that
if I were to leave the point 1 comma 1
in the direction of the vector 8i plus
4j if I were to leave in that direction
that would be the direction in which the
directional derivative would be maximum
and moreover that maximum
directional derivative will just be the
magnitude of this gradient vector the
magnitude of that gradient vector is
just the square root of 8 squared plus 7
squared which is the square root of 113
in other words what this tells us is
that the maximum directional derivative
leaving the point 1 comma 1 is the
square root of 113 and it occurs in a
direction 8i plus 7j as you leave the
point 1 comma 1
at any rate getting back to the
mainstream of the problem what we want
is a directional derivative in the
direction of s 1 that means what we take
our gradient vector which is 8 comma 7
and dot that with the unit vector in the
direction of s 1 you may recall from
this diagram here that the vector in the
direction of s 1 has its I component
equal to 3 its J component equal to 4
this makes this a 3 4 5 right triangle
so the unit vector in this direction has
as its components 3/5 and 4/5 in other
words the directional derivative of F at
the point 1 comma 1 in the given
Direction s 1 is just the gradient
dotted with the unit vector 3/5 I plus
4/5 J just mechanically carrying out
this operation leads to 52 over 5 and by
the way this had better turn out to be
less than this because this is what the
maximum value that the directional
derivative can have in other words if we
haven't made a mistake here one of the
check points is what that you can't get
a the vector can't project to be any
longer than what it really is in this
but I mean it can't be more than the
gradient vector but at any rate let's
now conclude the lecture by coming to
the part which is probably the hardest
thing that we're going to encounter in
the whole course in a way I feel a
little bit like the man who fell off the
Empire State Building and when he went
past the 40th floor some of they said
how you're doing and he said so far so
good and that is we've taken some
tremendous
is here and the biggest Liberty that
we've taken and it's not just a Liberty
it's the kind of a Liberty that the
solve involves the foundations of our
entire course we are now at the
grassroots of what functions at least
the calculus of functions of several
variables is all about and that's this
trouble spot first of all does Delta W
10 exist that's the first question
namely how do you know that there is a
tangent plane just because the surface
happens to be smooth when you cut it by
a plane parallel to the W Y plane and
smooth when you cut it by a plane
parallel to the W X plane how do you
know it's going to be smooth for any
given direction that's the first
intellectual question that comes up in
the reading assignment that has to be
solved effectively first of all does
Delta W tan exist meaningfully and
secondly if it does exist how is it
related to Delta W and now we come to
that key theorem the proof of which is
quite hairy it's done in the text it's
also done as an optional exercise to
help you generalize what's done in the
text and it's the counterpart of what
happens with differentials in functions
of a single real variable but the key
theorem which I'll stayed here without
proof is simply this suppose that W is a
function of x and y and that F sub X and
F sub y both happen to exist in some
neighborhood of the point a comma B all
right so far so good now here is the key
additional hypothesis suppose also that
F sub X and F sub y happened to be
continuous at a comma B my claim is is
that if this additional hypothesis is
obeyed the tangent plane will exist in
other words it's not enough for the
directional derivative to exist in the X
and y directions in order to guarantee
that the directional derivative will
exist in every direction but it is
enough provided that these directional
derivatives happen to be continuous and
by the way if these conditions are met
we say that F is a continuously
differentiable
function of x and y but I'll talk about
that more next time or in the notes are
in the exercises we're going to make a
big issue over there sooner or later but
for now what I do want to do is just end
with what the key theorem is the key
theorem says look at just like with one
variable if these conditions are met
then there is a very reasonable
approximation to Delta W by Delta W 10
namely what the theorem says is in this
case Delta W will be the partial of F
with respect to X evaluated at a comma B
times Delta X plus the partial of F with
respect to Y evaluated a comma B times
Delta Y and notice of course that this
is the thing that we've been calling
Delta Y 10 plus an error and the error
has the form k1 Delta X plus k2 Delta Y
where k1 and k2 both approach 0 as Delta
X and Delta Y approach zero and this is
very very crucial it's not enough as
we're going to see in the very next
lecture that Delta X and Delta Y
approach zero is that these things go to
0 as Delta X and Delta Y go to 0
consequently these terms go to 0 faster
they go to 0 as a second-order
infinitesimal and what this really says
is look for very small values of Delta X
and Delta Y even when you're dealing
with 0 over 0 forms if you pick a
sufficiently small neighborhood of the
point a comma B and that's the key point
a sufficiently small neighborhood of the
point a comma B then Delta W is
approximately equal to Delta W 10 and by
the way this holds also in several
variables in other words I picked the
case N equals 2 here simply so that we
could utilize the geometry namely what
we're saying is in terms of the geometry
if s happens to be a continuously
differentiable function of X and y and
we look at the surface W equals f of X Y
above the point a comma
what we're saying is that in a
neighborhood of that point there is but
first of all we're saying what a tangent
plane exists to the surface above that
point and that in a neighborhood of that
point of tangency the tangent plane is
an excellent approximation for the true
change in W now what happens is if n is
greater than 2 we can no longer use the
geometric interpretation but what is
important is that the analytic proof
never makes use of the picture and the
key point is and I'm going to exploit
this in future lectures the really key
point is that the Delta W 10 never gets
messy that the variables Delta X Delta Y
etc all occur as linear terms and this
is why the so called linear algebra
subject becomes so important in the
study of functions of several variables
at any rate I think this is enough for
one lesson and in our next lesson what
we will do is show how using this key
theorem has its analog in something
called the chain rule just as it did in
the case of part 1 when we studied
functions of a single independent
variable
at any rate then until next time goodbye
funding for the publication of this
video was provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate